Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. hello welcome to the rest is history as in the background we hear the beautiful voice from malia rodriguez dominic a wonderful fardo singer and i know that you are a huge huge fan of fardo aren't you it is the voice of portugal's
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告节目并访问我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，背景中传来了玛丽亚·罗德里格斯（Amália Rodrigues）美妙的歌声，多米尼克，她是一位出色的法多（fado）歌手，我知道你是法多的超级超级大粉丝，对吧？这是葡萄牙的声音，
regret for what had once been and um we uh we left portugal not in a good state uh lost brazil um very impoverished um and where are we in the 19th century what is it that gives rise to fardo um is there anything to hope for there's loads to hope for tom this is going to be an absolutely thrilling i mean you don't want to start on a downer do you this is going to be a thrilling podcast uh it's got music it's got football it's got fascism or or is it fascism well we will discuss that um it's got portuguese empire in the 20th century it's got world war ii so it's the podcast with everything. But as you say, we start in the aftermath of the Napoleonic Wars. So our third podcast, we were talking about early modern Portugal, about the earthquake and about the Enlightenment
对昔日岁月的眷恋与遗憾。我们……我们离开葡萄牙时的状况并不好，失去了巴西，变得非常贫困；那么我们在19世纪身处何方？是什么孕育了法多？那里还有什么值得希望的吗？有太多的希望了，汤姆，这绝对会是一期激动人心的节目。我的意思是，你总不想一上来就让人沮丧吧？这会是一期精彩绝伦的播客，它有音乐，有足球，有法西斯主义，或者说这是法西斯主义吗？好吧，我们会讨论这个。它有20世纪的葡萄牙帝国，还有第二次世界大战，所以这是一期无所不包的播客。但正如你所说，我们从拿破仑战争的余波开始讲起。所以在我们的第三期播客中，我们一直在讨论早期现代葡萄牙、关于那场地震、关于启蒙运动
and so on. Portugal has, as you say, lost Brazil in the 1820s. It does still have an empire. 19th century Portugal has Angola, Mozambambique east timor and goa for example so it has how and macau so it has a few sort of enclaves interestingly the portuguese don't really claim that that is an empire they come to describe themselves as a pluricontinental nation that's an excellent way to disguise an empire isn't it yes it is yes so these places are not colonies they're actually parts of they're indivisible parts of Portugal. It's about 19th century Portugal. I mean, it's basically a complete backwater.
等等。正如你所说，葡萄牙在19世纪20年代失去了巴西。它确实仍然拥有一个帝国。比如，19世纪的葡萄牙拥有安哥拉、莫桑比克、东帝汶和果阿，所以它有……还有澳门，因此它拥有一些类似飞地的地方。有趣的是，葡萄牙人并不真正宣称那是一个帝国，他们后来将自己描述为一个跨大陆国家。这真是伪装帝国的绝妙方式，不是吗？是的，确实如此。所以这些地方不是殖民地，它们实际上是……是葡萄牙不可分割的一部分。这是关于19世纪的葡萄牙。我的意思是，它基本上就是一个彻底的落后地区。
So rather like Spain, its history, its political history is to an outsider utterly bewildering and consists of endless coups and civil wars and arguments about constitutions and sort of feuding between liberals and conservatives. But that, in a way, is just the sort of surface stuff. And actually, beneath that, the picture is one of a very, very agricultural country that has not really embraced industrial modernity at all.
所以，就像西班牙一样，它的历史——它的政治历史——对外行来说完全令人费解，充满了无休止的政变、内战、关于宪法的争论，以及自由派和保守派之间的那种内部争斗。但从某种程度上说，这只是表面的东西。实际上，在这之下，展现在我们面前的是一个非常非常农业化的国家，它根本没有真正拥抱工业现代化。
It still has these two cities, Lisbon and Oporto, with very little industry, very little manufacturing. A great fact that I read in 1910, only about a fifth of workplaces that the Portuguese themselves describe as manufacturers, as Belgium, in the Netherlands, of big factories employing thousands upon thousands of people. That gives you a sense of how far behind, as it were, Portugal is. And rather like with Spain, that sort of sense of stagnation is accompanied by an enormous political turbulence. So administrations coming and going, people, kings and queens being deposed. And it's in this period, I think, that you get the Portuguese, you really get this sort of sense that the Portuguese have been ill-served by history, the golden age is behind them, and that their defining characteristic to outsiders comes to be this kind of melancholy and
它仍然只有里斯本和波尔图这两座城市，工业极少，制造业也非常落后。我读过一个很棒的事实：在1910年，只有大约五分之一的工作场所被葡萄牙人自己描述为制造企业，相比之下，像比利时和荷兰那样拥有成千上万名工人的大型工厂比比皆是。这让你意识到葡萄牙落后了多少。而且就像西班牙一样，这种停滞感伴随着巨大的政治动荡。因此，政府不断更迭，人们、国王和女王纷纷被废黜。我认为，正是在这段时期，你开始感受到葡萄牙人——你真正感受到这样一种感觉：葡萄牙人被历史亏待了，黄金时代已经过去，而他们对外行而言最鲜明的特征，就成了这种忧郁和
nostalgia. So that's saudade is that right that's saudade yes so for those people who i mean there's a great description by a british travel writer called aubrey bell um well he was a great hispanophile he wrote a book called in portugal in 1912 and he says the famous saudade of the portuguese is a vague and constant desire for something that does not and probably cannot exist, for something other than the present, a turning towards the past or towards the future, not an active discontent or poignant sadness, but an indolent, dreaming wistfulness. And there's this sort of sense that the defining characteristic of the Portuguese comes to be a kind of melancholy and a nostalgia
乡愁。所以那是 saudade（萨乌达德），对吗？那是 saudade，是的。所以对于那些人来说——我的意思是，有一位名叫奥布里·贝尔（Aubrey Bell）的英国旅行作家做出过极好的描述，他是一位伟大的西班牙文化爱好者，在1912年写了一本名为《在葡萄牙》（In Portugal）的书，他说：“葡萄牙人著名的 saudade 是一种对某种并不存在、且可能永远不会存在的事物模糊而持久的渴望，是对现实之外的事物的渴望，是对过去或未来的转向，它不是一种积极的不满或尖锐的悲伤，而是一种慵懒、梦幻般的惆怅。”人们有一种感觉，葡萄牙人的决定性特征变成了一种忧郁和乡愁，
and a kind of mourning for what had been what had been for husbands lost at sea for ancestors who vanished into the mists of time um it's this sort of yeah it's it's it's actually extremely enjoyable as an outsider you know it's romantic well it's it's Tolkien-esque isn't it it's actually extremely enjoyable as an outsider. You know, it's romantic. Well, it's Tolkien-esque, isn't it? It's very Tolkien-esque. It's the long defeat, all that kind of stuff that we were talking about last week. It's weird to be going back to Tolkien, but yeah, Tolkien, that thing about the elves mourning the passing of Middle-earth and all that. So that's all Sardar Day.
以及对往事的某种哀悼——哀悼那些在海难中丧生的丈夫，哀悼那些消失在时间迷雾中的祖先。这种感觉……是的，作为局外人其实非常享受，你知道的，这很浪漫。好吧，这很有托尔金式的风格，不是吗？作为局外人其实非常享受，你知道的，这很浪漫。好吧，这很有托尔金式的风格，不是吗？非常具有托尔金的风格。这就是漫长的失败，所有我们上周讨论过的那种事情。回到托尔金感觉怪怪的，但确实，托尔金，关于精灵哀悼中土世界消逝的那些事。所以这些都是 Saudade。
That's all Sardar Day. Yeah, the greatest Portuguese modern writer is the poet Fernando Pessoa. His poems are shot through with Saudade, with nostalgia and melancholy. And there's actually a statue of him in Lisbon, which sits outside a cafe in the Chiado district, so a very upmarket district.
这些全都是 Saudade。是的，最伟大的葡萄牙现代作家是诗人费尔南多·佩索阿（Fernando Pessoa）。他的诗作中处处弥漫着 Saudade，充满了乡愁与忧郁。事实上，在里斯本有一尊他的雕像，坐落在希亚多（Chiado）区的一家咖啡馆外，那是一个非常高端的街区。
There's the statue and he's sitting at a table. And the cafe is called A Brasileira, the Brazilian lady. And I always think that's very telling because, of course, Brazil is what has been lost. And Brazil is expanding and going from strength to strength. And the Portuguese are just sort of left to contemplate. So it's like us looking at America. A little bit, but we never have that with America, do we? I mean, Britain just simply doesn't have a sense of melancholy and nostalgia and mourning for America. I mean, most British people never think about the American War of Independence at all.
那里立着雕像，他正坐在一张桌子旁。这家咖啡馆名叫 A Brasileira，意为“巴西女郎”。我总觉得这意味深长，因为当然了，巴西正是失去的领土。巴西正在扩张，蒸蒸日上。而葡萄牙人却只能留下来沉思冥想。所以这就好比我们看着美国。有点像，但我们对美国从来没有那种感觉，对不对？我的意思是，英国人根本不会对美国产生忧郁、乡愁和哀悼之情。我的意思是，大多数英国人根本不会去想美国独立战争这回事。
Yes, that's very true. Yes. So the Saudade, you played the Fado at the beginning, and I guess the Fado is the defining cultural expression of that melancholy. Yes, very famous for that, isn't it? So you're not really a fadoophile, are you, Tom? I have a terrible sense that you played it ironically at the beginning of this podcast.
是的，这非常对。是的。所以 Saudade，你在开头播放了法多，我想法多就是这种忧郁最具代表性的文化表达。是的，法多以此闻名，不是吗？所以你其实并不是一个法多迷，对吧，汤姆？我有种可怕的感觉，你在这期播客开头播放它纯粹是在恶搞。
No, not at all. Since we started doing this, I thought this is the way to get into a Portuguese frame of mind. So I've been doing nothing but play it. So I got very into it. So I've learned something that's good so you've you've you've enriched me culturally oh Tom that's a nice thing to hear that's I've educated you something you've educated me yes well yeah I haven't educated myself I've been educated by you that makes me feel great but that's what this podcast is all about isn't it it's it's a self me educating you yeah this is my revenge for um i was only listening today it sounds it's a
不，完全不是。自从我们开始做这个节目以来，我就觉得这是进入葡萄牙人思维方式的途径。所以我一直在听它，因此我深深地迷上了。我学到了一些好东西，所以你……你……你在文化上丰富了我。哦，汤姆，听到这话真好，这说明我教育了你，你被我教育了，是的。好吧，是的，我没有自我教育，我是被你教育的，这让我感觉好极了。但这就是这档播客的意义所在，不是吗？这就是我教育你……是的，这是我的报复，因为……我今天才刚听……说出这种话真糟糕，居然听自己的播客，但我得去牙医诊所，我还得把儿子也强行带去牙医诊所。我把他留在车里，让他听你谈论 J.R.R. 托尔金。而他觉得特别搞笑的是，你把我和山姆·詹吉（Sam Gamgee）相提并论。当我接下来说话时，我说“汤姆”，而你纠正我说：“请叫我汤姆先生。”所以法多讨论引发了极大的欢乐。极大的欢乐。太欢乐了。
terrible thing to say that you've listened to your own podcast but i had to go to the dentist and i had to drag my son with me to the to when i went to the dentist and i left him in the car and i left him listening to to you talking about.R.R. Tolkien. And what he found particularly amusing was that you compared me to Sam Gamgee. And when I next spoke, I said Tom and you corrected me and said Mr. Tom to you. So the Fardo discussion. Much hilarity. Much hilarity. Much.
太欢乐了。
Great banter. Right. So Fardo music, it originates in Lisbon, in the port areas, people think. And it's all these ballads that are full of sort of nostalgia and stuff. The most famous fado singer of the 19th century was called Maria Severa. And she was the daughter of a prostitute and was a sort of prostitute herself. So you get this sort of sense of it being the music of the of the streets and the queen of fardo is amalia rodriguez and she is um the best-selling ever portuguese musical artist and she again comes from poverty
妙趣横生。好。所以法多音乐起源于里斯本的港口地区，人们认为是这样的。这全都是那些充满乡愁之类情愫的民谣。19世纪最著名的法多歌手名叫玛丽亚·塞维拉（Maria Severa）。她是一个妓女的女儿，自己也曾是个妓女。所以你会有一种感觉，认为它是街头音乐。而法多的女王是阿马利亚·罗德里格斯（Amália Rodrigues），她是葡萄牙历史上唱片销量最高的音乐艺术家，她同样出身贫寒。
she supposedly sold fruit on the keys of lisbon and she always performs wrapped in this kind of black shawl so she looks old-fashioned you know she looks kind of nostalgic rocking that retro look rocking that retro look exactly so she is one of the faces of 20th century portugal um so people outside portugal if you who you would recognize i would say ultimately there are three people so there there is amalia amalia rodriguez if you're interested in music if you're interested in sport probably the figure eusebio the pearl, and we'll come back to him. But the biggest figure by far, and the person with whom actually Amalia Rodriguez's musical career comes to be entwined, is the man who decides that he is going to put an end to the sort of the bickering and the turbulence and the inconsequentiality of Portuguese politics.
据说她曾在里斯本的码头卖水果，而且她演出时总是裹着一条黑色的披肩，所以她看起来很老派，你知道的，带着那种怀旧感，驾驭着复古风。驾驭着复古风，没错。所以她是20世纪葡萄牙的面孔之一。因此，对于葡萄牙以外的人来说，如果你要辨认的话，我可以说最终有三个人：一个是阿马利亚——如果你对音乐感兴趣的话；如果你对体育感兴趣，大概就是尤西比奥（Eusebio），也就是“黑豹”，我们稍后会谈到他。但其中最重要的人物，而且实际上其音乐生涯与阿马利亚·罗德里格斯的生涯交织在一起的那个人，是决定要结束葡萄牙政治中的争吵、动荡和无足轻重状态的那个男人。
And that is Antonio Salazar. So he's a pretty strange figure, Tom, isn't he? Well, you've described him to me as the Tolkien of Portugal, which considering that he's a highly reactionary dictator, isn't perhaps the most flattering reference to Tolkien. considering that he's a highly reactionary dictator. Isn't perhaps the most flattering reference to Tolkien. No, it's not. But, well, so we obviously recorded about,
他就是安东尼奥·萨拉查（Antonio Salazar）。所以他是个相当奇怪的人物，汤姆，不是吗？嗯，你曾向我描述他是“葡萄牙的托尔金”，考虑到他是一个极度反动的独裁者，这或许不是对托尔金最恭维的评价。考虑到他是一个极度反动的独裁者，这或许不是对托尔金最恭维的评价。不，确实不是。不过，好吧，我们显然录制了……
we did our podcast about Tolkien last week, so Tolkien was much in my mind when I was reading about Salazar. They're born only a few years apart. Salazar was born in 1889. When was Tolkien born again? Mid-1890s wasn't it um uh salazar he comes from a sort of you know it's not a particularly rich family his father is the manager sort of agricultural manager for some rich landowners in the center of portugal in the viseo district um young antonio is very very clever so he studies at a seminary and he trains to become a priest,
我们上周做了关于托尔金的播客，所以在读到关于萨拉查的资料时，托尔金的形象一直在我的脑海中浮现。他们出生的年份相差不远。萨拉查出生于1889年。托尔金是什么时候出生的来着？1890年代中期，对吧？呃……萨拉查，他出身于一个……你知道的，并不是一个特别富裕的家庭。他的父亲是葡萄牙中部维塞乌（Viseu）地区一些富裕地主的农业经理。年轻的安东尼奥非常非常聪明，所以他在神学院学习并接受培训成为一名神父，
but he doesn't go through with it. Like Tony Abbott. Tony Abbott. Yeah. So in fact, he's the Tony Abbott of Portugal. He's the Tony Abbott of Portugal. Those are three men who nobody, no other history podcast has ever put together.
但他没有坚持到底。就像托尼·阿博特（Tony Abbott）。托尼·阿博特。对。事实上，他就是葡萄牙的托尼·阿博特。他是葡萄牙的托尼·阿博特。这是三个从来没有被任何其他历史播客联系在一起的人。
Tolkien, Salazar, Tony Abbott. Tony Abbott, the prime minister of australia of course who featured in our yes prime ministers who ate an onion on the campaign trail didn't he that's right by he thought it was an apple and then just had to follow through with it pretend he liked it um but i'll tell you someone else who a friend of the show who he resembles is anastasius the um emperor who stabilizes the currency though he's not as bald as no he's not no salazar isn't bald but he is an accountant so i was thinking kind of yes famous accountants in history so he doesn't become a priest salazar he becomes an accountant that that rest is history
托尔金、萨拉查、托尼·阿博特。托尼·阿博特，当然是澳大利亚前总理，他曾在我们的……是的，曾在竞选活动中生吃洋葱的那位首相，对吧？没错，他以为那是个苹果，然后就只能硬着头皮假装自己很喜欢吃。不过，我告诉你另一个与他相似的节目之友，那就是安纳斯塔修斯（Anastasius），那个稳定了货币的皇帝……不过他没有那么秃。不，他没有。萨拉查不秃，但他是个会计。所以我当时在想，历史上有哪些著名的会计师？所以他没有当成神父，萨拉查，他成了一名会计。那期《历史的余烬》
episode on the top 10 accountants we We're a fifth of the way. We've got two of them. So, yes, he goes to Coimbra, the university that has played a part throughout this whole series because it's the great university of Portugal. And he studies law and finance there. And he becomes an economics professor at Coimbra in his mid-20s. Now, this is at a time, Tom, the Portuguese, it sounds harsh to call, I mean, I don't know whether it's cancelable now to call a country backward, even if it's a country in the past, but Portugal
关于十大会计师的节目，我们已经完成了五分之一。我们已经有了其中两个。所以，是的，他去了科英布拉大学，这所大学在整个系列节目中都扮演了重要角色，因为它是葡萄牙伟大的学府。他在那里学习法律和财政。他在二十多岁时成为了科英布拉大学的经济学教授。现在，这是一个这样的时代，汤姆，葡萄牙……把一个国家称为落后听起来可能有些苛刻——我的意思是，我不知道现在把一个国家称为落后是否会遭到“取消文化”的抵制，即使它是一个过去时代的国家——但葡萄牙
has been left behind by industrial modernity. Most Portuguese are still illiterate. And they're short, aren't they? Yeah, I mean, because of poverty. So they are ill-fed, they're ill-housed. So the Dutch are all huge and the Portuguese aren't. Well, exactly. So if they'd re'd refought those Dutch-Portuguese wars
已经被工业现代化远远抛在了后面。大多数葡萄牙人仍然是文盲。而且他们个子很矮，对吧？对，我的意思是，因为贫困。所以他们营养不良，居住条件恶劣。所以荷兰人都高大魁梧，而葡萄牙人则不然。完全正确。所以如果他们重新打起那些我们谈论过的荷兰-葡萄牙战争，
that we're talking about, Portuguese would have been in very poor shape to take them on. Exactly. And Salazar in his youth, I mean, he is intensely conservative and he watches as Portugal goes through these sort of almost comical kind of ructions. So 1910, after all these decades of instability, there's a revolution that overthrows the monarchy.
葡萄牙人在迎战时就会处于非常糟糕的状态。完全正确。而萨拉查在年轻时——我的意思是，他极其保守，他眼睁睁地看着葡萄牙经历这些几乎滑稽可笑的动乱。所以1910年，在经历了数十年的不稳定之后，爆发了一场推翻君主制的革命。
You have the first Portuguese Republic. So it's happening in kind of parallel, I suppose, with what's happening in Spain, which is better known. And the first Portuguese Republic, I think I'm not being too harsh when I say it's an absolute and utter shambles. So in 16 years, they have eight presidents, they have 44 different cabinets,
你迎来了葡萄牙第一共和国。所以这大概与西班牙正在发生的事情并行发生，而西班牙的情况更为人所知。我认为，说葡萄牙第一共和国是一个彻头彻尾的混乱局面，并不过分。所以在16年里，他们换了8位总统，44届不同的内阁，
they have 21 further coups or uprisings or revolutions of various kinds. So it's not, you know, it's basically, it makes Theresa May's Britain look like a... Yes, look like a model of stability. Paragon of stability. Massive inflation at the end of the First World War. The Portuguese had joined in the First World War
他们还发生了21次后续的政变、起义或各种形式的革命。所以这并不是……基本上，这让特雷莎·梅（Theresa May）时期的英国看起来像是一个……是的，看起来像是一个稳定的模范。稳定的典范。第一次世界大战结束时出现了严重的通货膨胀。葡萄牙是在一战进行到一半时加入同盟国一方的。
sort of halfway through on the Allied side. For the same reason it enters the Napoleonic Wars, that basically it's attached by commercial and sentimental ties to Britain. And so it kind of joins in. It absolutely makes sense for it to be supporting Britain and France because, I mean, obviously Britain and France are neighbours.
原因与它卷入拿破仑战争的原因相同，基本上是因为它与英国有着商业和情感上的纽带。所以它就加入了。它支持英法是绝对合乎情理的，因为很明显，英国和法国是邻国。
They're closer than Germany. But as you say, for commercial reasons, and because the Portuguese Empire basically depends on the goodwill of the British. Well, I'm ashamed to say I didn't even realise Portugal had entered the First World War. And I did not know, I'm reading that 8,000 competence, Portuguese competence die on the Western Front, which may not sound much. But to put that in context, if that was mapped onto the United States as it is now, that would be equivalent to 400,000 Americans dying. So quite brutal. So you've got that going on and you've got this kind of tension, presumably as in Spain, between liberals and devout Catholics.
它们比德国更近。但正如你所说，出于商业原因，以及因为葡萄牙帝国基本上依赖于英国的善意。好吧，我很羞愧地承认，我甚至没有意识到葡萄牙曾参加过第一次世界大战。我也不知道，我读到有8000名葡萄牙参战人员阵亡于西线，这听起来可能不算多。但为了说明问题，如果把这个数字映射到现在的美国，那就相当于400,000名美国人死亡。所以相当残酷。所以你看到了这些情况，并且你发现——可能就像在西班牙一样——自由派与虔诚的天主教徒之间存在着这种紧张关系。
Oh, absolutely. Huge tension between the Catholic Church. It's that classic pattern that you see in Spain and you see in Latin America, anti-clericals versus kind of clerical conservatives. And that presumably then is the backdrop for the most internationally famous thing that happens in Portugal during the First World War, which is the visions of Fatima, which is a village where a group of children who are working as shepherds, the Virgin appears to them. So first of all, it's announced by the Archangel Michael, and then the Virgin appears, and there are kind of increasing numbers of visitations. And then the Virgin announces that she's going to appear on the 13th of october so and did she 1917 so this is the backdrop you know the russian revolution is
哦，绝对的。天主教会之间存在着巨大的紧张关系。这就是你在西班牙和拉丁美洲看到的经典模式：反天主教派对阵天主教保守派。那么这大概就是葡萄牙在一战期间发生的最具国际知名度事件的背景，也就是法多（Fad…）——不对，法蒂玛（Fatima）显灵。法蒂玛是一个村庄，一群放羊的孩子在那里看到了圣母显现。首先，大天使圣米迦勒宣告了这一消息，接着圣母显现了，显灵的次数越来越多。随后圣母宣布她将在10月13日再次显现。那么1917年……这就是背景，你知道的，俄国革命让人感到世界上正在发生伟大事件。好吧，所以我来给你读一段由一位葡萄牙作家在1952年写下的关于当时所发生事情的记述：这群庞大的人群——圣母曾告诉这些孩子她将在10月13日显现——大批群众涌向那里，其中不仅有虔诚的天主教徒，还有许多前来看笑话的反天主教自由派人士。据说发生的情况是，云开雾散，太阳露了出来，它显示出一种奇异的颜色，然后太阳开始非常非常诡异地运转。它开始在轴心上眩晕般地旋转，就像人们能想象到的最壮丽的火轮，呈现出彩虹般的所有色彩，并发出多色的光芒，产生了最为惊人的
the sense that great events are happening in the world well i so i'll read you an account that was written by a portuguese writer in 1952 that what happens so this huge crowd that they've been the virgin has told these children that she's going to appear on the 13th of october um huge crowds turn up it's not just devout catholics it's also lots of of anti-clerical kind of liberals who've come to have to have a sneer and supposedly what happens is that the clouds clear and the sun appears and it's kind of displaying this strange color and then the sun starts to behave very very oddly it began to revolve vertiginously on its axis like the most magnificent fire wheel that could be imagined taking on all the colors of the rainbow and sending forth multi-colored flashes of light producing the most astounding
效果。这个崇高且无与伦比的奇观重复了整整三次，持续了大约10分钟。庞大的人群被如此巨大神迹的证据所折服，纷纷跪倒在地。所以关于当时究竟发生了什么，存在着巨大的争论。这是一场集体幻觉吗？这确实发生了，汤姆。人群中的巨量人数声称他们亲眼目睹了这一幕。所以……群众从不会出错，正如我们所知。是的，所以这对心理学家来说非常有趣，你知道的，集体妄想之类的话题，或者可能正是因为这种现象，才使得圣母在法蒂玛的显现在整个20世纪都具有如此大的影响力。人们有一种看法，
effect this sublime and incomparable spectacle, which was repeated three distinct times, lasted for about 10 minutes. The immense multitude, overcome by the evidence of such a tremendous prodigy, threw themselves on their knees. And so there's a huge debate about what was going on. Is it a mass hallucination? And this definitely happened, Tom. Huge numbers in the crowds claim to have seen this right so and crowds are never wrong as we know yeah so it's of huge interest to psychologists and you know yeah mass delusions whatever or maybe it was because it's it's that phenomenon that makes the vision of the virgin at fatima so influential throughout the 20th century and there's this idea that you
产生这种无与伦比的壮丽奇观，重复了整整三次，持续了大约10分钟。庞大的人群被如此巨大神迹的证据所折服，纷纷跪倒在地。因此，关于当时发生了什么，存在着巨大的争论。这是集体幻觉吗？这绝对发生了，汤姆。人群中有极多的人声称亲眼目睹了这一点，对吧，正如我们所知，群众从来不会出错，是的，所以这引起了心理学家的极高兴趣，你知道的，群体错觉之类的事情，或者也许是因为正是这种现象，使得法蒂玛的圣母显灵在整个20世纪都具有如此大的影响力，并且有一种观点认为你
know that there are three secrets and that John Paul II is supposed to have had one. You know, he was obsessed by Our Lady of Fatima. And this idea that- Who's got the others? Well, the Pope, the papacy has them, supposedly. Really? She revealed these three things were going to happen,
知道，有三个秘密，而若望·保罗二世据说知道其中一个。你知道的，他迷恋法蒂玛圣母。而这种观点认为——谁知道其他的？好吧，教宗，教宗职位掌握着它们，据说是这样的。真的吗？她透露这三件事将会发生，
one of which was the Russian Revolution. And then the two other great events that were going to happen so lots of people also thought that that when the um in in the shadow of nuclear war that perhaps the third vision was of the third world war but i don't know i i'm slightly slightly winging it here crikey what are the other what are the i want to know what the other secrets are of course you do of course you do. Of course you do. James Callaghan's victory in the 1976 Labour election. It was foretold. It was foretold. Yeah.
其中之一就是俄国革命。然后是另外两件将要发生的大事，所以许多人也认为，当在核战争的阴影下，或许第三个异象就是第三次世界大战，但我不知道，我在这里有点即兴发挥了。天哪，其他的秘密是什么，我想知道其他的秘密是什么，你当然想知道，你当然想知道。詹姆斯·卡拉汉在1976年工党选举中的胜利。这是预言中的。这是预言中的。是的。
And, oh, who knows? What were the other? The Pierce Brosnan's casting as James Bond in the early 1990s. But Dominic, calm down, calm down. I'm guessing that against the backdrop of the Russian Revolution, the war, the convulsions that are happening within Portugal, that this seeming vision of the Virgin must be quite influential on the willingness of people to give an ear to Salazar. Well, I think you're absolutely right that the visions of Fatima must reflect an immensely turbulent political and economic landscape
而且，谁知道呢？其他的会是什么？皮尔斯·布鲁斯南在20世纪90年代初被选为詹姆斯·邦德。但是多米尼克，冷静点，冷静点。我猜，在俄国革命、战争以及葡萄牙内部动荡的背景下，这个看似圣母显灵的景象必定对人们愿意听取萨拉查的意见产生了相当大的影响。嗯，我认为你完全说得对，法蒂玛的显灵必然反映了一个极其动荡的政治和经济格局，
in which people are looking for solace and looking for escapism. And the 1920s are a grim decade for Portugal. The late 1910s and early 1920s are a grim time. Lots of bombings, lots of assassination attempts. It really feels like Spain before the Spanish Civil War. So summon an accountant. Well, so they have a coup in 1926, an army coup. The army come in to try and run Portugal's affairs.
人们在其中寻求慰藉和逃避。20世纪20年代对葡萄牙来说是一个严峻的十年。10年代末和20年代初是一个严峻的时期。大量的爆炸，大量的暗杀未遂。这真的感觉就像西班牙内战前的西班牙。所以召集一个会计师。好吧，所以在1926年他们发生了一场政变，一场军队政变。军队介入试图管理葡萄牙的事务。
Portugal is crippled by massive, massive public debt as well as the inflation and all these other things. And the army say, well, let's get this bloke who's the professor of economics at Coimbra to come in and sort out the economy. A top boffin. A top boffin. Now Salazar has been, he was in parliament.
葡萄牙被庞大的巨额公共债务以及通货膨胀和所有这些其他问题压得瘫痪，军队说，好吧，让我们找这个担任科英布拉大学经济学教授的家伙来整顿经济。一个顶尖专家。一个顶尖专家。现在萨拉查曾经是，他曾在议会里。
He'd been briefly elected to parliament in 1921. He'd only gone once and he'd left because he said he was so disgusted. He's very anti-parliamentary. Like General Gordon going to see a ballet. Yes, I suppose so. So the comparison with, I mean, Tolkien, the comparison is only sort of partly tongue-in-cheek.
他在1921年曾短暂当选为议员。他只去过一次就离开了，因为他说他感到非常厌恶。他非常反议会制。就像戈登将军去看芭蕾舞一样。是的，我想是的。所以与……我的意思是，托尔金，这种比较只是半开玩笑的。
Tolkien in Britain, to give a British comparison, he's somebody who is, as we said before, very reactionary, very ultra-Catholic, very anti-modern. You know, you said his model of politics was a kind of sacral kingship. He sees himself as a conservative anarchist and all this sort of thing. Salazar, too, dislikes parliamentary democracy, dislikes modernity. But he's not in any way an anarchist, is he?
英国的托尔金，如果要给出一个英国的比较，他是一个正如我们之前所说，非常保守、极其天主教、非常反现代的人。你知道，你说他的政治模式是一种神圣君主制。他认为自己是一个保守的无政府主义者以及诸如此类的事情。萨拉查也是，不喜欢议会民主，不喜欢现代性。但他绝不是一个无政府主义者，对吧？
No, he's not in any way an anarchist. I mean, that is one of many differences. And he doesn't write about hobbits. No, he doesn't. Okay, there are lots of differences. He's not from Birmingham. He's got no interest in ancient finnish so never read bear wolf dominic i'm afraid the differences are actually amounting up but let's park that comparison i had thought tom they were identical people but now you've proved me wrong so i taught
不，他绝不是无政府主义者。我的意思是，那是众多不同点之一。而且他不写霍比特人。不，他不写。好吧，有很多不同点。他不是来自伯明翰。他对古代芬兰语毫无兴趣，从没读过《贝奥武夫》，多米尼克，我恐怕这些不同点真的在增加，但我们暂且搁置这个比较吧。汤姆，我曾以为他们是同一个人，但现在你证明我错了，所以我教了
you about fardo you've taught me that there were two different people we've educated each other we have we both learned something. Live on a podcast. They called in Salazar in 1926, and they say, will you be the finance minister? And basically he does it for five days. He does it for five days, and then he gets on the train and goes back to Coimbra, and he says, you won't let me do what I want, which is to cut spending and to do all these reforms.
你关于法多音乐的知识，你教了我其实有两个不同的人，我们互相教育了对方，我们都学到了东西。在播客直播中。他们在1926年把萨拉查请去，他们说，你愿意当财政部长吗？基本上他干了五天。他干了五天，然后他就上火车回科英布拉了，他说，你们不让我做我想做的事，那就是削减开支和进行所有这些改革。
So I'm not going to do it and actually this becomes his his modus operandi for the rest of the 1920s they keep dragging him back and saying be the finance minister and sort out the accounts and he keeps threatening to resign and every time he threatens to resign they just give him more power basically so that by 1928 he becomes finance minister sort of permanently as it were and he gets from the president who's a guy called carmona who's a sort of he's a republican and he's another freemason actually um carmona basically says okay fine you have complete right of veto on all the other departments so you can basically be running the government from the finance ministry and then by 1932 he becomes prime minister and really when i say prime minister i mean he basically is the government so everybody else does what he tells he has almost quasi dictatorial power even though he's only prime minister not president and he's only
所以我不会干了。事实上，这成为了他在20世纪20年代其余时间里的行事方式，他们不断把他拉回来，说当财政部长并整顿账目，而他不断威胁要辞职，每次他威胁辞职时，他们基本上就会给他更多的权力，以至于到1928年他基本上变成了常任财政部长，并从总统卡尔莫纳那里获得了权力，卡尔莫纳是一个某种程度上是共和党人而且实际上还是个共济会成员的家伙，卡尔莫纳基本上说，好吧，行，你对所有其他部门都拥有完全的否决权，所以你基本上可以从财政部运行政府，然后到1932年他成为了首相，真的，当我说是首相时，我的意思是，他基本上就是政府，所以其他所有人都听从他的指示，他拥有几乎准独裁的权力，尽管他只是首相而不是总统，而且他只是
prime minister for the whole all the decades that he's in control in Portugal. Yeah, he's never president. He's always prime minister serving at the discretion of the president. So how is he maintaining power? I mean, what are the underpinnings, the kind of the practical underpinnings? The practical underpinnings are he does sort out the economy. So he does sort out Portugal's debt and he starts running balanced budgets um they've had incredible turbulence yeah and they recognize that he is an incredibly clever and hard-working man of this kind of flinty slightly terrifying integrity uh he also has an enormous appeal to catholic conservative middle-class conservatives and of course he's a very useful
在他控制葡萄牙的几十里里一直担任首相。是的，他从来都不是总统。他总是担任首相，听命于总统。那么他是如何维持权力的呢？我的意思是，支撑基础是什么，某种实际的支撑基础是什么？实际的支撑基础是他确实整顿了经济。所以他确实整顿了葡萄牙的债务，并开始实行平衡预算，嗯，他们经历了难以置信的动荡，是的，他们认识到他是一个非常聪明且极其勤奋的人，具有这种坚定且略带可怕的正直，嗯，他对天主教保守派、中产阶级保守派也有着巨大的吸引力，当然他是一个非常有用
tool for the big landowners, for the army, for the Catholic Church, because they have found somebody who is exceedingly competent, who will protect their interests from socialism, Bolshevism, anarchism. And his thing is, he freezes in place the status quo. But what I'm trying to understand is the degree to which he is a dictator, or whether his position in power depends on him having the backing of powerful blocks within the state. Well, I think that's probably true of all dictators, isn't it, Tom? That they actually, the fantasy that we have, which is that they're Bond villains. Well, no, becauseler is a fuhrer
的工具，对大土地所有者、军队、天主教教会而言，因为他们找到了一个极其称职的人，他将保护他们的利益免受社会主义、布尔什维克主义、无政府主义的侵害。而他的做法是，他将现状冻结在原地。但我试图理解的是，他在多大程度上是一个独裁者，或者他在权力中的地位是否取决于他拥有国家内部强大集团的支持。嗯，我想对于所有独裁者来说这大概都是真的，不是吗，汤姆？他们实际上，我们心中的幻想是他们是邦德反派。不，因为希特勒是一个元首
mussolini is a duche i mean they indisputably stand at the head of the state and they have a kind of they they claim a heroic status by virtue of that i mean if if salazar is is just the prime minister yeah you know he's not even the president then that is that is quite a difference isn't it this is what makes him tom and, such a richly fascinating study. Because, as you say, he appears to be in many ways, I mean, you make the comparisons with Hitler and Mussolini. Or indeed Franco would be the... Oh, Franco.
墨索里尼是一个领袖，我的意思是他们无可争议地站在国家首脑的地位，并且凭借这一点声称具有某种英雄般的地位，我的意思是如果萨拉查只是首相，是的，你知道他甚至都不是总统，那么这确实是一个相当大的区别，不是吗？这就是为什么他，汤姆，是一个如此极其迷人的研究对象。因为正如你所说，他在许多方面似乎，我的意思是，你把他与希特勒和墨索里尼作比较。或者实际上佛朗哥将是……哦，佛朗哥。
So there'll be lots of people who've listened to this and have heard us jokingly make the Tolkien comparison and will bridle because they will think Salazar is a fascist and J.R.R. Tolkien wasn't a fascist. But Salazar, in some ways, he wears a business suit. He's very frugal. He's just the prime minister. He doesn't have rallies.
所以会有很多人听到这里，听到我们开玩笑地做托尔金式的比较，然后会心生戒备，因为他们会认为萨拉查是个法西斯分子，而J.R.R.托尔金不是法西斯分子。但萨拉查在某些方面，他穿着商务西装。他非常节俭。他只是首相。他没有集会。
He has no rallies. He has no personality cult. He doesn't really have a political party. So they have a new constitution, a corporatist constitution. He has a single party, the National Union, which he basically sells as a non-party. He has no interest in mobilizing the masses. He doesn't really sell himself as anything other than a technocrat, so the public, sort of Catholic technocrat. There's no sense of energizing young people. There's no sense of embracing modernity,
他没有集会。他没有个人崇拜。他实际上没有一个政党。所以他们有一部新宪法，一部法团主义宪法。他有一个单一政党，即国民联盟，他基本上把它作为非政党来推销。他对动员群众毫无兴趣。他没有把自己推销为技术官僚以外的任何人，所以公众，某种天主教技术官僚。没有让年轻人充满活力的感觉，没有拥抱现代性的感觉，
of military expansion, of all these other aspects of the hyperactive, the hysterical side of 1920s fascism. He has none of that. So on his propaganda posters, he portrays himself as figures from Portugal's heroic past. So he compares himself to John of Braganza, Jau of Braganza. He does indeed. And actually, so the great historian of fascism, Robert Paxton, says that one of the confusing things about Salazar is that Salazar, he copies often the language and the iconography, which is so common in the 1920s and 30s, of fascism.
没有军事扩张的感觉，没有20世纪20年代法西斯主义过度活跃、歇斯底里一面的所有这些其他方面。他完全没有这些。所以在他的宣传海报上，他把自己描绘成葡萄牙英雄过去的人物。所以他把自己比作布干萨的约翰，布干萨的若昂。他确实如此。事实上，法西斯主义伟大的历史学家罗伯特·帕克斯顿说，关于萨拉查令人困惑的事情之一是，萨拉查，他经常模仿法西斯主义在20年代和30年代非常普遍的语言和图像学。
So you see a Salazarist monument or you see a Salazarist poster, and they do look very fascistic. But the difference is that it has none of the dynamism or the excitement or the radicalism that fascism holds out, which is so intoxicating to younger voters often in the 20s, so Mussolini's Italy, let's say. Everything that Salazar is trying to do, it's quite a depersonalized regime.
所以你看到一个萨拉查主义的纪念碑或一张萨拉查主义的海报，它们看起来确实非常具有法西斯色彩。但不同之处在于，它没有任何法西斯主义所具有的活力、兴奋感或激进主义，而这种活力对20年代的年轻选民往往具有如此强的迷幻作用，比方说墨索里尼的意大利。萨拉查试图做的所有事情，都是一个相当去个性化的政权。
So the image of him that's presented to the public is this sort of mr he's very frugal um he's unmarried he doesn't like the trappings of power he's kind of monkish monkish exactly monkey an academic an academic actually and people often say you know he's he governs like a professor he works all the time in his office he doesn't he doesn't believe in the heating because he thinks it's wasteful so he's or like a professor. He works all the time in his office. He doesn't believe in the heating because he thinks it's wasteful. Or like a schoolteacher, a teacher treating the Portuguese. Portuguese as children. So, Tom, I was just going to say, you'll enjoy this.
所以向公众呈现他的形象是这样一个先生，他非常节俭，嗯，他未婚，他不喜欢权力的浮华，他有点像修士，修士般地，确切地说，像个修士，一个学者，一个学者，人们经常说，你知道他统治得像个教授，他一直在办公室里工作，他不相信暖气，因为他认为那是浪费，所以他或者像个教授。他一直在办公室里工作。他不相信暖气，因为他认为那是浪费。或者像个学校老师，一个把葡萄牙人当作孩子的老师。所以，汤姆，我正要说，你会喜欢这个的。
You know, we talked in the last podcast about that bloke who wouldn't take his coat off. Yeah. Dom João. Salazar won't take his coat off in the winter because he doesn't believe in heating. So he works in his overcoat. Well, a model there for everyone in europe this witness do as salazar did that's that's a slogan um um but but so if he's a school teacher school teachers have the right to punish their pupils their students yes so what is the apparatus of control that Salazar is exercising? There's a secret police that goes through various incarnations.
你知道，我们在上一期播客里谈到过那个不肯脱大衣的家伙。是的。多姆·若昂。萨拉查冬天不肯脱大衣，因为他不相信暖气。所以他穿着大衣工作。好吧，这为欧洲的每个人树立了一个榜样，见证者要像萨拉查那样做，那是一个标语，嗯，但是，但是，如果他是一个学校老师，学校老师有权利惩罚他们的学生，他们的学生，是的，那么萨拉查正在行使的控制机构是什么？有一个经历了各种演变的秘密警察。
It's best known as the PIDE. And they have prisons. Do they have concentration camps? They have political prisons, I think it's fairer to say, rather than concentration camps per se, for dissidents. I mean, we'll come after the break to some of the suppression of dissidents in the post world war ii era but they do people do die and people do disappear and and one of the reasons that salazar is so much debated and that in a way he seems such
它最为人所知的是PIDE。他们有监狱。他们有集中营吗？我认为更公平的说法是，他们有政治监狱，而不是严格意义上的集中营，用来关押异见人士。我的意思是，我们在中场休息后会讨论二战后时代对异见人士的一些镇压，但确实有人死亡，也确实有人失踪，而萨拉查之所以备受争议，并且在某种程度上他似乎是一个
an ambiguous figure is that on the one hand people disappear and die on the other hand the numbers by comparison with other 20th century societies are not very great so i i found it i was researching this podcast i found it very hard to find a definitive figure which probably tells you its own story so it's maybe between 50 and 100 people in portugal and how many how many decades is the impact over so what we're talking from the mid 1920s to 1968 1970 so that's quite a long time i mean you could say one or two people a year are tortured to death in prison beaten up by the secret police um are disappeared right by his secret police but portugal doesn't have the death penalty so the death penalty had been abolished in the late 19th century he doesn't he doesn't reintroduce it no he does not reintroduce it so he has what's
模棱两可的人物，一方面是有人失踪和死亡，另一方面与20世纪的其他社会相比，人数并不是非常多，所以我发现，我在研究这个播客时，发现很难找到一个确切的数字，这可能说明了它自己的故事，所以葡萄牙可能大约有50到100人，而影响跨越了多少个年代？所以我们谈论的是从20世纪20年代中期到1968年、1970年，所以这是一段相当长的时间，我的意思是你可以说每年有一两个人被折磨至死在监狱里，被秘密警察殴打，嗯，被秘密警察失踪，对吧，但是葡萄牙没有死刑，所以死刑在19世纪后期就被废除了，他没有，他没有重新引入它，不，他没有重新引入它，所以他拥有
called his estado novo his new state again you know that's very very 20s 30s kind of dictatorship isn't it to talk of a new state but the difference between his new state and mussolini or hitler is he doesn't want to lead Portugal into a new age. He wants to lead it back, doesn't he? He wants to stop the clock. So this is your Tolkien comparison. He wants to go back to a Catholic medieval. Catholic feudal society, virtually.
被称为他的“新国家”（Estado Novo）的东西，同样你知道，谈论一个新国家非常具有20世纪20、30年代那种独裁统治的特色，不是吗？但他的新国家与墨索里尼或希特勒的区别在于，他不想引导葡萄牙进入一个新时代。他想引领它倒退，不是吗？他想让时钟倒转。所以这是你对托尔金的比较。他想回到一个天主教中世纪。几乎是一个天主教封建社会。
I mean, just, you know, he doesn't. There are changes. So people become more literate. There are new schools. There are all these kinds of things. And the economy is run more competently than it had been in previous decades but really he doesn't want anything to change i mean it's a wonderful story that um when someone told him much later in the 60s i think the oil had been discovered in angola which you would think he would be delighted by he said yes oh what a pity yes well that that's also very tolkien well i
我的意思是，只是，你知道，他并不是完全没有改变。所以人们识字率更高了。有了新的学校。有所有这些各种各样的事物。而且经济的运作比前几十年更有能力，但实际上他不想改变任何事情，我的意思是这是一个极好的故事，嗯，当很久以后在60年代有人告诉他，我想安哥拉发现了石油，你本以为他会为此高兴，他说“是的，哦，太遗憾了”，是的，嗯，这也是非常托尔金式的，好吧
think listen let's let's take a break now and then when we come back um as it were dig a little deeper uh and describe his relation with with hitler with franco with mussolini and what happened second world war and then the aftermath of that so we'll see you back in a few minutes i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment in a few minutes. episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hola y bienvindo a Oresto e Historia. Tom, we are nearing the end of our great Portuguese odyssey. We are. And you have introduced this extraordinary figure, Antonio Salazar, dictator or is he dictator of Portugal, this kind of monkish figure. And before the break, you were talking about him in relation to the fascist leaders. If Salazar is a devout Catholic,
我想听着，我们现在休息一下，然后等我们回来，嗯，顺便说一句，更深入地挖掘一下，并描述他与希特勒、佛朗哥、墨索里尼的关系，以及第二次世界大战中发生了什么，然后是之后的结果，所以我们几分钟后再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐就是一切》，几分钟后见。关于剧集以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertaninment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。您好，欢迎收看《其余与历史》。汤姆，我们即将结束我们的伟大葡萄牙奥德赛之旅。确实如此。你介绍了这位非凡的人物，安东尼奥·萨拉查，葡萄牙的独裁者，或者他是独裁者吗，这个有点像修士的人物。在中场休息之前，你一直在谈论他与法西斯领导人的关系。如果萨拉查是一个虔诚的天主教徒，
what is his attitude to the kind of the pagan strain, say, within Nazism? Well, that's exactly what he would call it. Do you know, he would love your book Dominion. You would have had great chats with Salazar about Dominion, Tom. Okay, I don't quite know how to feel about that. So Salazar does think that Nazis are pagan. So he's a very, very reactionary Catholic, and he hates Bolshevism socialism all of this stuff which he
他对待纳粹内部那种异教倾向的态度是什么？嗯，这正是他会称呼它的方式。你知道吗，他会喜欢你的书《多米尼恩》（Dominion）。汤姆，你本可以和萨拉查就《多米尼恩》进行一次很好的聊天的。好吧，我不太清楚该对此作何感想。所以萨拉查确实认为纳粹是异教徒。所以他是一个非常非常保守的天主教徒，他讨厌布尔什维克主义、社会主义所有这些他
sees as godless and evil so from that point of view he sees the fascists as a i suppose a useful bulwark against it but on the other hand he he goes he says he describes hitler and the nazis as he says they are pagan they're incompatible with the character of our Christian civilization. There are attempts to have kind of overtly fascist movements in Portugal, as there are in every other European country. In Portugal, it's a group called the Blue Shirts. Salazar basically purges them, denounces them. He condemns, and it's interesting, he condemns what he calls the exaltation of youth, the cult of force through direct action, the principle of the superiority of state political power and social life, and the propensity for organizing masses behind a single leader. And that's actually a pretty good academic definition of fascism.
他认为这是一个没有信仰的、邪恶的东西，所以从这个角度来看，我猜他把法西斯主义看作是对抗这种现象的一个有用的屏障；但另一方面，他却把希特勒和纳粹描述为异教徒，他说这些与我们基督教文明的特质格格不入。葡萄牙曾试图建立那种公开的法西斯运动，就像其他每个欧洲国家一样。在葡萄牙，这是一个名为“蓝衫军”（Blue Shirts）的组织。萨拉查基本上清洗了他们，并谴责了他们。他谴责——有趣的是——他谴责了他所说的对青年的美化、通过直接行动崇尚武力的崇拜、国家政治权力在社会生活中至高无上的原则，以及将群众组织在一个领袖身后的倾向。这其实是对法西斯主义相当不错的学术定义。
And he basically says all of that is bad. He very much sounds like the kind of chap who would not be in favor of the exaltation of youth definitely not a man for the exaltation of youth no is is there something jacob reese moggish about him no i don't well maybe i'm revealing too much about my opinion of jacob reese mogg but i don't think there's anything at all contrived about so jacob reese mogg loves the media and he loves to appear on the media and the the persona is very carefully calibrated you know to get publicity salazar hates publicity he he's genuinely monkish he's very austere um he's not going to be giving quotes to channel 4 news right he's not rich no he's not well he's i mean he's not badly off i mean he has a summer house and he has
而他基本上说这一切都是不好的。他听起来很像那种绝对不会赞成美化青年的人，绝对不是一个赞成美化青年的人，不，他身上是不是有什么雅各布·里斯-莫格式的特质？不，我不——好吧，也许我暴露了太多我对雅各布·里斯-莫格的看法，但我不认为雅各布身上有什么刻意的东西。所以雅各布·里斯-莫格喜欢媒体，他喜欢在媒体上露面，而且他的人设经过了非常精心的校准，你知道的，为了博取曝光度；而萨拉查讨厌曝光，他真的像个修士一样，非常简朴，嗯，他才不会给第四频道新闻（Channel 4 News）提供引言呢，对吧？他不富有？不，他不——嗯，他也不是手头很紧，我是说他有一座避暑别墅，还有
his residence and stuff but is he corrupt he's not corrupt he's not no i don't think he's especially corrupt actually i mean he's definitely he works with people who are corrupt and you could like all dictatorships his regime has plenty of corruption but personally personally, he lives with this extraordinary personal life. So he works all the time. Life magazine said, very insulting to the Portuguese actually, the American magazine Life said of him, he is everything that most Portuguese are not, calm, silent, ascetic, puritanical, a glutton for work, cool to women.
他的住所之类的地方，但他腐败吗？他不腐败，他不——不，我不认为他特别腐败，其实，我是说他确实——他与腐败的人共事，而且你可以像所有独裁政权一样，他的政权有大量的腐败，但就他个人而言，就他个人而言，他过着一种非同寻常的个人生活。所以他整天都在工作。《生活》杂志曾说——这对葡萄牙人其实非常侮辱——美国《生活》杂志这样评价他：他具备了大多数葡萄牙人不具备的一切特质——冷静、沉默、苦行、清教徒式、对工作狂热、对女性冷淡。
But he lives with this housekeeper called donna maria um so she's she's a sort of peasant she was initially a sort of illiterate sort of servant woman who basically stays with him as his housekeeper is that in inverted commas housekeeper well people have said isn't it mysterious that he has this sort of live-in companion and um she had two nieces that he was very kind to so some of his portuguese opponents said oh these are obviously his children i don't think that's true i don't think they were an extraordinary thing that when she died in 1981 so 11 years after salazar the director of the care home where she had been living decided
但他和一位名叫多娜·玛丽亚的管家生活在一起，嗯，所以她是一个类似农民的人，最初是一个目不识丁的女仆，基本上一直留在他身边做他的管家。这是带引号的管家吗？好吧，人们曾说，难道不是很奇怪吗，他有这样一个同居伴侣，而且嗯，她有两个侄女，他对她们非常好，所以他的一些葡萄牙政敌就说，哦，这显然是他的孩子。我不认为那是真的，我不认为他们是——一件非同寻常的事情是，当她在1981年去世时，也就是萨拉查去世11年后，她一直居住的那家疗养院的院长决定
that for the sake of her reputation, she must be basically exhumed. And he would have her examined to see if she was still a virgin. And was she? Apparently she was. So yeah, I mean, that is very bizarre. So properly monkish, yeah. But the other comparison is, I mean, let's state the comparison, not just with Hitler, but with Mussolini and Franco. Mussolini is all about strutting.
为了她的名誉，必须基本上将她开棺验尸。他要让人检查她是否还是处女。那她是吗？显然是的。所以，是的，我的意思是，这非常诡异。所以确实很有修士的风范，对吧。但另一个对比是——让我们说说这个对比——不仅是与希特勒的对比，还有与墨索里尼和佛朗哥的对比。墨索里尼整天昂首阔步，
It's about pomposity. It's about display and swagger and this sort of almost comical kind of virility. Salazar, it's inconceivable. You cannot picture him on the balcony addressing great crowds. Franco is incredibly corrupt. I mean, Franco is a very unlikable man. Salazar can't really stand Franco. Franco is a great show-off.
讲究浮华，讲究炫耀、神气活现，以及这种几乎带有滑稽色彩的男子气概。而萨拉查，这简直不可想象。你无法想象他在阳台上向乌压压的群众发表讲话。佛朗哥极其腐败。我是说，佛朗哥是一个非常惹人厌恶的人。萨拉查其实忍受不了佛朗哥。佛朗哥是个爱显摆的人，
He's all about, you know, lots of medals, lots of pomp, lots of display. His family become incredibly rich. Again, Salazar has none of this. So one of the things that I suppose makes him almost uncomfortable to study is that in some ways, he's the kind of person that when we're writing about political leaders, we're often tempted to find quite admirable in quite a chilly way, because he does have this kind of seriousness and integrity. But of course, he is running a very repressive
他整天——你知道的，满身勋章、满面威风、大肆炫耀。他的家人变得极其富有。同样，萨拉查完全没有这些。所以，我想让他几乎变得难以被客观研究的原因之一是，在某些方面，他正是那种当我们在撰写关于政治领导人的文章时，往往会忍不住以一种相当冷峻的方式报以敬佩的人，因为他确实具备这种严肃性和正直感。但当然，他掌管着一个高度压迫、
incredibly reactionary regime in which you you know the free speech is limited um the newspapers there's huge censorship um and political dissidents are jailed if not tortured i mean i suppose you could put it this way if you were given the choice to lead your life through the 30s and 40s in Italy, Spain, Germany, or the USSR, or Portugal, you'd probably go for Portugal. Yeah, you would. I'm sure you would. I'm sure you would. And in fact, that's the interesting question, isn't it? So given where Portugal is, it's on the European peripheryy given its economic and political condition um so which is analogous to spain maybe italy or greece i suppose or indeed countries of latin america i mean portugal is sleep is terribly sleepy and stagnant in the middle of the 20th century but at the same time you know it
极其反动的政权，在那里，你知道的，言论自由受到限制，嗯，报纸存在巨大的审查制度，嗯，政治异见人士遭到关押，甚至遭受酷刑。我是说，我想你可以这样看待它：如果你有机会选择在30年代和40年代的意大利、西班牙、德国、苏联或葡萄牙度过你的一生，你大概会选择葡萄牙。是的，你会的。我敢肯定你会的。我敢肯定你会的。事实上，这就是那个有趣的问题，不是吗？鉴于葡萄牙所处的位置，它地处欧洲边缘，鉴于其经济和政治状况——
doesn't have coups it doesn't have a civil war right it doesn't have mass repression mass terror all of these kinds of things so you know best of a bad lot maybe the best of a bad job or i mean who knows the alternative to salazar probably wasn't was a civil war a happy successful democracy it might well have been yeah more bombings more terrorism more and he keeps portugal out of the Second World War? Well, yes and no, actually, interestingly. So it's basically the Peninsular War all over again. So Salazar is sort of relatively benevolently disposed towards the Nazis.
这可能类似于西班牙、也许还有意大利或希腊，我想，或者确实是拉丁美洲的国家——我是说，葡萄牙在20世纪中期死气沉沉、停滞不前，但与此同时，你知道的，它没有发生政变，没有内战，对吧，没有大规模镇压、大规模恐怖活动以及所有这些类型的事情。所以，你知道的，矬子里拔将军也许吧，或者说两害相权取其轻，或者——谁知道呢，萨拉查的替代方案可能不是内战和幸福成功的民主政体，很可能就是——是的，更多的轰炸、更多的恐怖主义、更多的——而且他让葡萄牙置身于第二次世界大战之外？嗯，是的，也不是，事实上，有趣的是。所以这基本上就是又一次的半岛战争。所以萨拉查对纳粹的态度相对来说比较宽容。
He's not, you know, by the standards of people's attitudes to the Nazis. You know, he's so anti-communist that in some ways they could be natural allies. But on the other hand, of course, Britain is all important. So Britain, even in the 19th and early 20th century, still accounts for a huge proportion, something like a quarter, I think, of Portuguese imports. And, you know, it's a dominating kind of economic factor. So he can't alienate the British, but also he's terrified of alienating the Germans. He doesn't want to jump into bed with the British because he thinks Lisbon will be bombed
他并不是，你知道的，以人们对纳粹的态度为标准。你知道的，他是如此反共，以至于在某些方面他们可能会成为天然的盟友。但另一方面，当然，英国至关重要。所以英国，甚至在19世纪和20世纪初，仍然占葡萄牙进口额的很大一部分，我记得大约四分之一左右，而且，你知道的，这是一个主导性的经济因素。所以他不能疏远英国人，但同时他也害怕疏远德国人。他不想和英国人同床异梦，因为他认为里斯本会遭到轰炸，
and Portuguese bases will be bombed and so on. So basically, right at the beginning, he squares it with the British. He says, we're still your allies, but we're going to remain neutral in this war. And the British are completely fine with that. They understand that and they actually confirm that. They send him a kind of diplomatic note saying that's completely fine. And in fact, when Churchill comes in, I mean, the British go out of their way to say to Salazar, it's fine that you're neutral. Thank you for being neutral. So Churchill sends Salazar a personal letter in the autumn of 1940. I commend you for all you're doing. Look after your country and all this.
葡萄牙的基地会遭到轰炸等等。所以基本上，就在一开始，他就和英国人把事情摆平了。他说，我们依然是你们的盟友，但我们在这场战争中将保持中立。英国人对此完全没有意见。他们理解这一点，并且实际上对此予以确认。他们给他发了一份类似外交照会的信件，说这完全没问题。事实上，当丘吉尔上台时——我是说，英国人特意对萨拉查说，你们保持中立没关系。感谢你们保持中立。所以在1940年秋天，丘吉尔给萨拉查写了一封私人信件：我赞赏你所做的一切。照顾好你的国家以及诸如此类的话。
Churchill gets Oxford University to give Salazar an honorary degree. He must have liked that, I guess. I bet he loved that. Yeah, of course. They upgrade the embassy and they send a very distinguished diplomat, Sir Ronald Campbell, to be the British ambassador to Portugal to say, look how seriously we take you. The Portuguese have a big exhibition in 1940 to celebrate the anniversary of the founding of Portugal as a kingdom in 1140 and its independence from Spain in 1640 and the British go out of their way to send the Duke of Kent so a senior member of the royal family to represent them even in wartime at this exhibition in Portugal to show Salazar how much they think of him and what what the British get
丘吉尔让牛津大学授予萨拉查荣誉学位。他一定喜欢那个，我猜。我敢打赌他一定很喜欢。是的，当然。他们升级了使馆，并派了一位非常杰出的外交官罗纳德·坎贝尔爵士（Sir Ronald Campbell）担任英国驻葡萄牙大使，以表明我们是多么重视你们。1940年，葡萄牙举办了一场大型展览，以庆祝1140年葡萄牙王国建国及其在1640年从西班牙独立的历史周年纪念，英国人甚至在战时也不惜特意派遣肯特公爵——王室的高级成员——代表他们出席葡萄牙的这场展览，向萨拉查展示英国人对他的高度评价。那么英国人从
out of that well they get two things so one they're very keen to keep getting tungsten Portugal is a is a supplier of tungsten wolfram, as it's sometimes called. And they're supplying it to both Britain and Germany. And actually, there's incredible scenes at the beginning of the war where British and German agents are sort of rushing to villages to get their supply, competing to get their hands on these. It's a very good setting for spy thrillers, isn't it? It is.
中得到了什么呢？嗯，他们得到了两样东西：第一，他们非常渴望继续获取钨。葡萄牙是钨——有时被称为黑钨矿——的供应国。而且他们同时向英国和德国供应钨。事实上，战争初期出现了令人难以置信的场景，英国和德国的特工争先恐后地赶往各个村庄以获取供应，竞相抢夺这些资源。这非常适合作为间谍惊悚片的背景，不是吗？确实如此。
There's loads of spy thrillers set in Portugal, in lisbon in the 1940s so they get that but the thing that they want above all is the azores so the azores as an atlantic base and they are quite sort of they they they take their time before asking for it so really they only get the azores they only ask for the azores once it's kind of obvious that they're going to win salazar had a plan that if the germans attacked portugal he would evacuate to the azores with brit he'd do a peninsular war style the british would evacuate him the british would evacuate him but in 1943 the british under because the americans keep saying why don't we ask get the azores from portugal the british ask um salazar for the azores to if they can use these bases they actually have a plan that if he says no it's
有大量的间谍惊悚片以1940年代的葡萄牙里斯本为背景。所以他们得到了这个，但他们最想要的还是亚速尔群岛——作为大西洋基地的亚速尔群岛。他们花了相当长的时间才提出这个要求——实际上，直到很显然英国人要获胜时，他们才得到了亚速尔群岛，才向萨拉查索取亚速尔群岛。萨拉查曾有一个计划，如果德国人进攻葡萄牙，他就与英国一起撤退到亚速尔群岛，他会效仿半岛战争的风格，英国人会撤离他，英国人会撤离他。但在1943年，英国人在——因为美国人不断说，为什么我们不去向葡萄牙索取亚速尔群岛呢？——英国人向萨拉查索取亚速尔群岛，看他们是否能使用这些基地。他们甚至制定了一个计划，如果他拒绝的话，
called operation brisk your brother would enjoy this tom they would have all these landing craft and they would seize the azores themselves a bit like we did it with iceland but they don't need to do it because actually salazar says yes and so the british are able to he says as long as you know you don't use any sort of portuguese planes or you don't implicate us you can use these bases which we do so the british use the azores so we're very grateful to salazar for that so that's why he stands so high in western esteem and sort of anglo-american esteem anyway at the end of world war ii when hitler dies doesn't he fly the flags at half mast does he I think he does right so Eamon de Valera
这被称为“轻快行动”（Operation Brisk）——汤姆，你一定会喜欢这个的——他们会动用所有这些登陆艇，自己占领亚速尔群岛，有点像我们对冰岛做的那样。但他们不需要这样做，因为实际上萨拉查同意了。因此英国人能够——他说，只要你知道的，你们不使用任何葡萄牙飞机，或者不把我们牵连进去，你们就可以使用这些基地。我们也确实这么做了。所以英国人使用了亚速尔群岛，因此我们为此非常感激萨拉查。这就是为什么他在西方受到的尊崇如此之高，无论如何，在二战结束时受到的英美尊崇如此之高。当希特勒死时，他不是降半期致哀了吗？他是吗？我想他是的，对吧？所以埃蒙·德瓦莱拉——
Eamon de Valera yes and uh actually he's probably got on well with Eamon de Valera I don't know they seem quite similar types yes yeah yeah so there we've got so now it's the quartet Tolkien Eamon de Valera Salazar and Tony Abbott the bad monks um but but the other thing is uh is refugees which is really interesting so the portuguese save thousands of people from hitler and the interesting question is whether this is because of salazar or despite salazar so definitely he says to the portuguese consuls there are some people you should let in so So, for example, the last Habsburg empress, Zita, and her son, Otto, they are rescued through the help of the Portuguese. Because Otto von Habsburg had actually been sentenced to death by the Nazis.
埃蒙·德瓦莱拉，是的，而且——其实他可能和埃蒙·德瓦莱拉很合得来。我不知道，他们看起来是相当类似的类型。是的，是的，是的。所以现在我们有了——现在有了四人组：托尔金、埃蒙·德瓦莱拉、萨拉查和托尼·阿博特——这几个坏修士。但是——但另一件事是——难民问题，这真的很有趣。葡萄牙人从希特勒手中拯救了数千人，而有趣的问题是，这是因为萨拉查，还是尽管有萨拉查？所以毫无疑问，他对葡萄牙领事说，有些人你们应该放进来。所以，
He goes on to become an MEP into the 1990s and beyond. So they are rescued by the Portuguese. But there are also these amazing stories about Portuguese diplomats who basically give out thousands and thousands of visas to Jews in France. The most famous one is a guy called Aristides de Souza Mendes, and he's the consul in Bordeaux. And he was declared, was it, righteous among the nations? Yeah, in Israel.
例如，哈布斯堡王朝末代皇后齐塔（Zita）和她的儿子奥托（Otto），他们在葡萄牙人的帮助下获救了。因为奥托·冯·哈布斯堡实际上已被纳粹判处死刑。
In Israel, because he, I mean, people argue about how many he gave out. He may well have given out tens of thousands. Some people say that's exaggerated, but I think it's plausible. Tens of, I mean, literally sort of like confetti to people to try and get them out, give them Portuguese visas so that they can escape before the Nazis catch up with them. And actually, that guy, Sousa Mendes, when the Portuguese had this big vote to decide who was the greatest Portuguese in history, he came third.
他后来在20世纪90年代及以后成为了一名欧洲议会议员。所以他们被葡萄牙人救了。但也有这些令人惊叹的故事：葡萄牙外交官基本上向法国的犹太人发放了成千上万的签证。最著名的一个人叫阿里斯蒂德斯·德·苏索萨·门德斯（Aristides de Souza Mendes），他是驻波尔多的领事。他被宣布为——是什么来着？——国际义人？是的，在以色列。
So who came first? Salazar. Salazar won 41% of the vote. Now, this is in 2007. Wow. Fascinating. That is fascinating. I think one of the biggest margins, because there are lots of it.
在以色列，因为他——我是说，人们对究竟发出了多少签证存在争论。他很可能发放了数万份。有些人说这被夸大了，但我认为这是合理的。数万份——我的意思是，简直像纸屑一样撒向人们，试图让他们逃生，发给他们葡萄牙签证，以便他们在纳粹追上他们之前逃跑。而事实上，那个叫苏索萨·门德斯的人，当葡萄牙举行这场盛大的投票来决定谁是历史上最伟大的葡萄牙人时，他获得了第三名。
This TV show, for those people who don't know, was modeled on the BBC series Great Britain. So there are lots of imitators all over the world. And Salazar, I think, won with one of the biggest pluralities of anybody who did win. How fascinating. Fascinating. Okay. Yeah. And that's presumably because, well, as we were saying before the break, he holds Portugal together.
那么谁得了第一名呢？萨拉查。萨拉查获得了41%的选票。现在，这是在2007年。哇。太迷人了。这太迷人了。我想这是最大的优势之一，因为有很多这样的节目。
There's no civil war. There's a measure of stability. He keeps Portugal out of the Second World War. But then going into the 50s and 60s, so into the Cold War, the Americans and NATO quite keen to have a staunch anti-communist on their side. Absolutely. He's a founder member of NATO. And so what's the apparatus of repression is it does it become worse after the war or much of a muchness uh does it become worse it's certainly maybe more overt and maybe more glaring so the most famous
这个电视节目，对于那些不知道的人来说，是模仿BBC的系列节目《伟大不列颠》（Great Britain）制作的。所以在世界各地有很多模仿者。而萨拉查，我认为他以所有获胜者中最大多数的票数之一赢得了胜利。太迷人了。太迷人了。好的。是的。这大概是因为——正如我们在休息前提到的那样，他把葡萄牙凝聚在了一起。
example of this is 1958 now as we said before the before the break salazar was never president he was always prime minister so actually he served at the discretion of successive presidents. Even though he runs the government, he is the big man. They defer to him. He has lots of rich and influential friends. But in 1958, an Air Force general called Humberto Delgado, who was actually the founder of TAP, the Portuguese airline, still the Portuguese national flag carrier. He says, I'm going to run in this presidential election as an independent as an independent candidate and during the campaign
没有内战。有一定的稳定性。他让葡萄牙置身于第二次世界大战之外。但随后进入50和60年代，也就是进入冷战时期，美国人和北约非常希望有一位坚定的反共人士站在他们一边。完全正确。他是北约的创始成员国。那么镇压机构是怎样的呢？在战后变得更糟糕了，还是大同小异？嗯，它变得更糟糕了吗？它当然也许变得更加公开，也许更加显眼。所以最著名的
somebody says uh will you what would you do when you're elected he says well the first thing i do would be to sack salazar as prime minister and from that point on was people call him general sem middle the general without fear because this is a thing that you just don't say yeah it's like saying as a senator saying i'm going to take down augustus similar kind of yeah precisely and actually to do what tom i thought about augustus when i was reading up on salazar there's a the best book in english by the way is by a guy called tom gallagher who is a professor at the university of bradford because Augustus, not altogether dissimilar, made a big public show of his frugality and his kind of, I'm an ordinary Roman,
例子就是1958年。正如我们之前在休息前所说的那样，萨拉查从未当过总统，他一直是首相。所以实际上，他是听命于历任总统的。尽管他掌控着政府，他是大人物。他们都听从他。他有很多富有且有影响力的朋友。但在1958年，一位名叫翁贝托·德尔加多（Humberto Delgado）的空军将军——他实际上是葡萄牙航空（TAP）的创始人，葡萄牙至今仍是其国家载旗航空——他说，我要作为独立候选人参加这次总统选举。在竞选期间，
and just holding an office by the will of the Senate, all that sort of stuff. But going back to Humberto Delgado, Tom, Humberto Delgado runs and he gets actually 25% in the presidential election. But most people think if it had been a real free election, he could have won. He might well have got more than 50%. After the election, for his temerity, he is expelled from the army and eventually exiled. But in 1965, Humberto Delgado is lured into what seems like an ambush on the Spanish border. He's lured back over the border and murdered by the secret police. Probably they were hoping to kidnap him and bring him to Portugal for trial. And his death, the death of somebody so high profile,
有人问他，嗯，你当选后会做什么？他说，嗯，我做的第一件事就是撤换首相萨拉查。从那一刻起，人们称他为“无畏将军”（General sem Medo），因为这是一件你根本不能说的事情。是的，这就好比一个参议员说，我要打倒奥古斯都。类似的一种——是的，确切地说。实际上，为了做成这件事，汤姆，我当阅读关于萨拉查的资料时想到了奥古斯都。有一本——顺便说一句，英文中最好的书是由布拉德福德大学教授汤姆·加拉格尔（Tom Gallagher）写的——因为奥古斯都，与他并非全无相似之处，在大众面前大力作秀，表现出自己的节俭以及那种“我是一个普通的罗马人，
a guy who'd been a presidential candidate seven years earlier, that is, I think, the moment where it becomes obvious to the world who had sort of not really been looking at Portugal. Peopleugal people say you know what this regime is actually pretty unpleasant so it's in 1965 i mean it's it's a year of help swinging 60s i mean it's all kicking in and there's a funny tom gallagher says in his book you know 1966 um was it the year of the beatles revolver salazar is sitting around at the table with his sort of aides complaining about the Reformation, the French Revolution. Wow, that's very Tolkien behaviour.
仅仅凭借元老院的意志担任公职”之类的姿态。但回到翁贝托·德尔加多，汤姆，翁贝托·德尔加多参选了，他在总统大选中获得了25%的选票。但大多数人认为，如果这是一场真正自由的选举，他本可以获胜。他很可能会获得超过50%的选票。选举结束后，因为他的鲁莽，他被开除出军队并最终流亡。但在1965年，翁贝托·德尔加多被诱骗进入了西班牙边境的一个看似伏击圈的地方。他被诱骗越过边境，并被秘密警察谋杀。可能他们是希望绑架他并把他带回葡萄牙受审。而他的死，一个如此备受瞩目的人的死——
Yeah, it is very Tolkien behaviour. So to go back to the comparison with Augustus' Bread and Circuses, the circuses, Salazar is, as you said, a very austere figure, not a guy who you'd associate with fun. He's not Captain Fun. But he does start to so there's this phrase fatima for religion we've talked about fatima fardo for nostalgia he doesn't really approve of fardo but he comes to accept that he you know it's it's quite useful to him yes and
一个在七年前曾是总统候选人的人——我认为，这就是那一刻，对于那些之前没有怎么关注葡萄牙的世界来说，一切变得显而易见。葡萄牙人说，你知道吗，这个政权其实相当令人不快。所以那是1965年——我是说，这是摇摆的60年代的一年，我是说一切都在进行中。汤姆·加拉格尔在他的书中写了一个有趣的事情，你知道的，1966年——那是披头士乐队的专辑《左轮手枪》（Revolver）发行的那一年吗？萨拉查正和他的助手们围坐在桌旁，抱怨着宗教改革和法国大革命。哇，这非常托尔金。
football for the glory of portugal yeah so those three things fatima is bringing in tourists and pilgrims um so that's all good the fado as you absolutely say fado was the music of the streets it had a kind of radicalism to it but what happens after the war is fado becomes kind of slightly tamed and the nostalgia the nostalgia is kind of turned up to 11
是的，这非常托尔金。所以回到与奥古斯都“面包与马戏”的对比，所谓的马戏，萨拉查正如你所说，是一个非常清教徒式的人物，不是那种你会和“乐趣”联系在一起的人。他可不是“欢乐队长”（Captain Fun）。但他确实开始——所以有这样一句话：“法蒂玛是为了宗教”——我们讨论过法蒂玛——“法多是为了乡愁”——他其实并不太赞同法多，但他逐渐接受了，他觉得——这对他相当有用。是的，而且
and that figure who brought us into the show Amalia Rodriguez kind of in her black shawl singing these laments. The Salazar, she's not a Salazarist, but the regime, and in fact,
“足球是为了葡萄牙的荣耀”。是的，所以这三样东西：法蒂玛吸引了游客和朝圣者，嗯，所以这都很好；法多——正如你绝对所说的那样，法多曾是街头音乐，它带有一种激进主义色彩，但战后发生的事情是，法多变得有点被驯化了，而乡愁——这种乡愁被拉到了最大。
Salazar despises her, but the regime use her, you know, to, to, to sell abroad this image of Portugal as an unchanging, you know, old fashioned country of,
那个把我们带进节目的阿马利亚·罗德里格斯（Amalia Rodriguez），披着黑披肩唱着这些悲歌。萨拉查——她并不是一个萨拉查主义者，但这个政权，事实上，
of true Catholics and, and stuff. So there's that. And then there's football and football in both Spain and Portugal in the 1950s and 1960s becomes an enormous asset to those regimes. I was reading that the journalists reporting on the Portuguese national team or Portuguese clubs playing other clubs from other countries that um they the journalists would get in trouble if for any lack of patriotic hyperbole which I think is something
萨拉查鄙视她，但这个政权利用她，你知道的，向海外兜售葡萄牙的这种形象：一个永恒的、你知道的、老式的、充满真正的天主教徒等等的国家。所以有这个。然后就是足球。在1950年代和1960年代的西班牙和葡萄牙，足球成为了这些政权的一笔巨大资产。我看到报道说，报道葡萄牙国家队或葡萄牙俱乐部对阵其他国家俱乐部的记者，
that we could profitably introduce here we could absolutely do with that Tom British sports writers yeah take note all they do is moan isn't it well this podcast Tom um is produced by Gary Lineker's company and maybe you should you've educated me in this podcast. Maybe you should have a word with Gary and say – Yeah. You know, take a more Salazarist approach to Match of the Day and the World Cup. To reporting on England at the World Cup. Yeah.
如果缺乏任何爱国主义的夸张言辞，记者就会惹上麻烦——我认为这是我们可以获利引入的东西。我们绝对可以引入这个，汤姆。英国体育记者们，请注意。他们所做的只是抱怨，不是吗？嗯，这个播客，汤姆，是由加里·莱因克尔（Gary Lineker）的公司制作的，也许你应该——你在这个播客中教育了我。也许你应该跟加里谈谈，说——是的。你知道的，对《当日比赛》（Match of the Day）和世界杯采取一种更倾向于萨拉查主义的方法。在报道英格兰队参加世界杯时。是的。
Halfways with Jonathan Wilson as well. Sort him out. Exactly. But, no, these are glory days for Portuguese football. Because Benfica, the big Lisbon team, they win the European Cup, the ancestor of the Champions League in 1961 and 62. They're finalists three times.
对乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）也一样。把他理顺。确切地说。但是，不，对葡萄牙足球来说，这是黄金时代。因为本菲卡，里斯本的大球队，在1961年和1962年赢得了欧洲冠军杯（欧冠联赛的前身）。他们曾三次打入决赛。
After that in 63, 65, 68, Portugal gets the semifinals in England in 1966. And this is, of course, the heyday of Eusebio. And Eusebio, and Eusebio is a he is probably the single most internationally famous Portuguese person before Cristiano Ronaldo famous for his history of the church and his biography of Constantine right well well Eusebio is interesting because of course he's he's black so he's born in Mozambique from a very poor family. And what I think is fascinating about Eusebio is Eusebio becomes this international avatar of Portugal at a point at which Portugal's relationship with those colonies, with Mozambique, with Angola, is increasingly strained. So as we said, they'd always said, they're not an empire, we're a pluricontinental nation. But obviously, by the mid 1960s, you know...
此后在63、65、68年，葡萄牙在1966年的英格兰打入了半决赛。而这当然是尤西比奥（Eusebio）的全盛时期。而尤西比奥——尤西比奥是一个——他可能是克里斯蒂亚诺·罗纳尔多之前国际上最著名的葡萄牙人，他以其教会史和君士坦丁传记而闻名？好吧——尤西比奥很有趣，因为当然，他是黑人——所以他出生在莫桑比克的一个非常贫困的家庭。而我认为尤西比奥最迷人的地方在于，尤西比奥成为了葡萄牙在国际上的化身，而此时葡萄牙与这些殖民地——与莫桑比克、安哥拉——的关系日益紧张。正如我们所说，他们一直宣称，我们不是一个帝国，我们是一个跨洲国家。但显然，到1960年代中期，你知道的……
Well, they lose Goa, don't they? Yes, they've lost Goa in the 60s. So there's a brilliant story about that, that the Indian army was kind of, you know, moving in on Goa, Nehru sends the tanks in, and the military authorities in Goa send a telegram to the general staff in Lisbon requesting sausages. And sausages is code for cannon shells. And the general staff sent a whole batch of pork sausages. To actually send them sausages.
嗯，他们丢了果阿（Goa），对吧？是的，他们在60年代失去了果阿。所以有一个关于此的精彩故事，当时印度军队正——你知道的——步步逼近果阿，尼赫鲁派出了坦克，果阿的军事当局向里斯本的总参谋部发了一封电报，请求“香肠”。而“香肠”是炮弹的代号。总参谋部却发去了一整批猪肉香肠。实际上给他们寄去了香肠。
They literally sent them sausages because they'd forgotten that this was the code. Oh, brilliant. So Goa Falls becomes part of India again. Yeah. And by the late 1960s, there have been uprisings in Angola and Mozambique in what becomes Guinea-Bissau. And, you know, the Portuguese are very dependent on – they're still dependent, actually, on Britain and on the United States.
他们真的给他们寄去了香肠，因为他们忘了这是代号。哦，太棒了。所以果阿沦陷了，再次成为了印度的一部分。是的。到1960年代末，安哥拉、莫桑比克以及后来的几内亚比绍都爆发了起义。而且，你知道的，葡萄牙人非常依赖——他们仍然依赖，实际上，依赖英国和美国。
Salazar is becoming boxed in. He's becoming increasingly, you know, his friends are South Africa and Rhodesia. So the breakaway regime in Rhodesia. And he's sort of supporting the Ian Smith regime in Rhodesia. So actually Mozambique becomes one of the world's most important kind of trading centers because all Rhodesian trade has to be funneled through Mozambique to break the boycott. But the spending on the army to try and fight off the sort of nationalist uprisings in Africa is absorbing more and more of the Portuguese budget. So in total, 8,000. So the same is similar to the First World War, actually, Tom. About 8,000 Portuguese are killed fighting in Angola and Mozambique in the late 60s.
萨拉查正把自己逼进死胡同。他越来越——你知道的，他的朋友是南非和罗得西亚。也就是罗得西亚的分离政权。他某种程度上在支持罗得西亚的伊恩·史密斯（Ian Smith）政权。所以实际上莫桑比克成为了世界上最重要的贸易中心之一，因为所有罗得西亚的贸易都必须通过莫桑比克输送，以打破抵制。但是，为了击退非洲的民族主义起义而对军队的开支正在消耗葡萄牙越来越多的预算。所以总共，8000人。所以实际上与第一次世界大战相似，汤姆。大约8000名葡萄牙人在60年代末在安哥拉和莫桑比克的战斗中丧生。
And presumably the Portuguese economy is still very much flatlining at this point. Yeah. I mean, what has grown, so all Western European economies have grown after World War II. So Salazar's defenders will often say, look, look howugal portugal's economy grew in the you know 1940s 1950s 1960s i think the truth probably is that whoever you know mickey mouse could have been prime minister of portugal and it would have grown but you're right portugal's economy is still it is still the poorest country in western europe it can ill afford these african wars and there's a definite sense i think by the late 1960s,
而且想必葡萄牙经济在此时依然非常平淡无奇。是的。我是说，增长的是什么呢——所以所有西欧经济体在二战后都实现了增长。所以萨拉查的辩护者经常会说，看，看看葡萄牙经济在1940年代、1950年代、1960年代是如何增长的。我想事实可能是，无论你是谁——米老鼠本可以担任葡萄牙首相，经济也会增长——但你是对的，葡萄牙的经济仍然是西欧最贫穷的国家，它无力承担这些非洲战争。而且我想到了1960年代末，有一种明确的感觉：
that this guy who was reactionary even by the standards of the 1920s, who's still running the country. So he's still running the country in 1968. So there's Soissons-Wittard out on the streets, and the hair is long, and the joystick's are burning. And he's fulminating against Martin Luther. Yeah. So what happens to him? He's at his house,
这个即使以20世纪20年代的标准来看也是反动的人，仍然在统治着这个国家。所以他直到1968年还在统治着这个国家。所以当时巴黎街头爆发了“五月风暴”（Soissons-Wittard）——呃，是索邦大学（Sorbonne）——人们留着长发，催泪瓦斯在燃烧。而他还在痛斥马丁·路德。是的。那么他怎么了？他在他的房子里，
his sort of summer residence. There are different accounts, but I think the most likely thing is he falls off his chair. Some people say it's in the bath, but I think it's his chair. On the 3rd of August 1968 and he suffers a brain hemorrhage. He appears to get better, but after two weeks
他的某种避暑官邸。有不同的说法，但我认为最有可能的情况是他从椅子上摔了下来。有些人说是在浴缸里，但我认为是在椅子上。那是1968年8月3日，他遭受了脑溢血。他看起来有所好转，但在两周后，
he goes into a massive decline. He goes into hospital. He goes into a coma. The president, who's sort of one of these identikit, slightly faceless kind of military conservative types, he thinks Salazar must be about to die. So he formally dismisses him as prime minister. And he gets another academic, actually, the former rector of Lisbon University, one of Salazar's old associates called Marcelo Caetano, a very distinguished constitutional lawyer. You know, it's weird that there's this dictatorship of academics,
他的病情急剧恶化。他住进了医院。他陷入了昏迷。总统——这是一个典型的、面目模糊的军方保守派类型的人——他认为萨拉查一定快要死了。所以他正式免去了他的首相职务。他换上了另一位学者，实际上是里斯本大学的前校长、萨拉查的老同僚之一马塞洛·卡埃塔诺（Marcelo Caetano），一位非常杰出的宪法法庭律师。你知道，奇怪的是竟然存在这样一个由学者、
of university professors. So Caetano becomes prime minister. But Salazar doesn't die. He lives for another 23 months. And nobody tells him is he conscious he's conscious he's lucid he's been in a coma for i think a month um but nobody says you're no longer prime minister i mean they basically say well he's kind of giving orders and people pretend to obey them i think he's he's in it i mean he's obviously not complete he's 80
大学教授组成的独裁政权。所以卡埃塔诺成为了首相。但萨拉查并没有死。他又活了23个月。而且没有人告诉他——他是清醒的吗？他是清醒的，他神志清醒，他昏迷了大约一个月，但没有人告诉他“你不再是首相了”。我是说，他们基本上说——好吧，他还在下达命令，人们假装在服从。我认为他身处其中——我是说，他显然不完全是——他80岁了，
he's he's obviously not you know functioning at the peak of dynamism. And people are saying to him... Like Joe Biden. Well, I think Joe Biden is still president, isn't he? I mean, unless things are happening behind the scenes that we don't know. Yeah, I mean, I've seen very exaggerated stories about this where people say,
他显然不是在——你知道的——以巅峰的活力在运转。人们对他说……就像乔·拜登。嗯，我认为乔·拜登现在还是总统，不是吗？我是说，除非幕后发生了我们不知道的事情。是的，我是说，我见过关于此事的非常夸张的报道，人们说，
oh, the Lisbon newspapers produced fake editions, which were shown to Salazar every day so that he would think he was still prime minister. I find that hard to believe that a newspaper would go to such ludicrous lengths for almost two years. But I think they didn't tell him he'd been sacked. And, you know, he just thinks that my deputies are doing the work and I'm sort of sitting here at home recuperating. And then eventually in 1970, he dies and the regime, well, we will come back to the fate of the regime and the last Western European revolution, which takes place in the 1970s. I think we should come back to that, shouldn't we, Dom? Yes, as part of this exciting package of projects that we have coming your way in November. So we won't say anything more. We'll just kind of tantalize you with that. So you're an outsider to this, as it were.
哦，里斯本的报纸印制了假版面，每天拿给萨拉查看，好让他以为自己还是首相。我觉得很难相信一份报纸会为了将近两年时间而采取如此荒谬的手段。但我认为他们没有告诉他他已经被解雇了。而且，你知道，他只是认为我的副手们在工作，而我正坐在家里疗养。最后在1970年，他去世了，而这个政权——嗯，我们会回过头来谈谈这个政权的命运，以及发生在1970年代的西欧最后一场革命。我想我们应该回到这个话题上，对吧，多姆？是的，作为我们在11月份带给你们的这系列激动人心的项目的一部分。所以我们不会多说。我们只会用这个来吊你们的胃口。所以你对此是个局外人，可以说是这样。
You've not written about Portuguese history, but you are obviously really interested in the Catholicism and the political Christianity, I suppose. So what's your take on him? I'm intrigued by the degree to which he clearly had, he must have had a measure of popular support. Because if he, I mean mean if his security apparatus i mean it sounds repressive but it's not the gestapo is it no it's grim and i don't want to downplay it
你没有写过葡萄牙历史，但你显然对天主教和政治基督教非常感兴趣，我想是的。所以你对他的看法是什么？我很好奇他显然拥有一定程度民众支持的程度。因为如果他——我是说，如果他的安全机构——听起来具有压迫性，但它又不是盖世太保，对吧？不，它是冷酷的，我不想淡化这一点，
because there'll be some portuguese listeners to this by and large the traditional fascist states they make a virtue of being repressive they they rub people's noses in it um if he's not doing that then he must have a measure of support and i I guess the fact that 40% vote for him in this poll suggests that it's ongoing. That is, I guess, unsettling if you're for narratives of liberal, you know, the perspective of democracy and liberalism, to imagine that someone who is so reactionary and so clearly repressive could have maintained such popular support for so long. Well, what's interesting is he's become quite fashionable in some circles in recent years. So the magazine, the American Conservative, published a big essay a couple of years ago called Waiting for Salazar, basically saying, you know, he's the philosopher king, post-liberal age. But was he a philosopher king? Dean Acheson, who was the Truman Secretary of State, he described him as the closest thing the 20th century
因为这里会有一些葡萄牙听众——大体上，传统的法西斯国家以实行压迫为荣，他们把这强加给人们；如果他没有这样做，那么他一定拥有一定程度的支持。我想，在这项民意调查中有40%的人投票支持他，这表明这种支持仍在持续。如果你支持叙利亚的自由主义叙事——你知道的，民主和自由主义的视角——去想象一个如此反动且明显具有压迫性的人竟然能维持如此长时间的民众支持，我想这确实让人感到不安。嗯，有趣的是，近年来他在某些圈子里变得相当时髦。所以《美国保守党》（The American Conservative）杂志几年前发表了一篇长篇大论，名为《等待萨拉查》（Waiting for Salazar），基本上是说，你知道的，他是后自由主义时代的哲学王。但他是一个哲学王吗？迪安·艾奇逊（Dean Acheson），杜鲁门时期的国务卿，他将萨拉查描述为20世纪最接近柏拉图式哲学王的人。我是说……但柏拉图式的哲学王出了名地具有压迫性。我是说，我想我同意。我认为他是一个令人不安的——奇怪的是，他是一个令人不安的人物，因为他是如此暧昧不清。因为关于他的一些事情，工作伦理，严肃性，那——关于法西斯主义，你知道
had to a platonic philosopher king. I mean... But platonic philosopher kings are famously repressive. I mean, I think I agree. I think he is an unsettling... It's odd that he's an unsettling figure because he's so ambiguous. Because there are things about him, the work ethic, the seriousness that... The thing about fascism, you know
谁是好人，谁是坏人。谁是坏人非常非常清楚。嗯，我猜萨拉查是——我是说，听起来他是一个比那稍微复杂一点的人物，你不能仅仅——是的，100%参与到那种好人和坏人的划分中去。我想那是对的，汤姆·加拉格尔的传记作家所说的是，他要暧昧得多，实际上很难用某种道德主义的标签来定义他——无论如何，所以他不是——他暧昧得多。实际上，很难用道德主义的标签来框定他。不管怎样。所以他不是种族主义者。他是种族主义者吗？
who the goodies and the baddies are. It's very very clear who the baddies are uh i i guess salazar is i mean he sounds as if it's slightly more complicated figure than that that you can't just yes 100 engage in the kind of goodies and baddies that's i think that's right that's what tom gallagher's biographer says is that he's much more ambiguous and actually it's very hard to kind of pin him down and with a moralistic kind of kind of label um anyway so he's not he's much more ambiguous. And actually, it's very hard to kind of pin him down with a moralistic kind of label. Anyway. So he's not racist. Is he racist?
不是种族主义者。我不会说他是那种明显公开的种族主义者。但也许一些葡萄牙听众会比我更清楚这一点。但我认为种族主义——我是说，他不是——例如，他不是公开的反犹主义者。人们在1930年代和1940年代经常说，
Not racist. Not massively overtly racist, I wouldn't have said. But I mean, maybe some Portuguese listeners will know more about this than me. But I don't think the racism... I mean, he's not... So for example, he's not overtly anti-Semitic. And people often said in the 1930s and 1940s,
葡萄牙的罕见之处在于其反犹太主义如此之少。现在实际上，我认为佛朗哥比萨拉查要反犹得多。嗯，我认为葡萄牙有这样一种传统：对犹太人口去了阿姆斯特丹感到遗憾，并觉得他们真的——对，他们被掠夺了。是的，你知道的，那是一个可怕的错误。某种程度上可以说是对“本该如何”的一种渴望，所以也许这正是其中的一部分，我不知道。汤姆，你被转化成卢西菲利（Lusiphile，葡萄牙文化爱好者）了吗？
Portugal is unusual in being in having so little antisemitism now actually franco i would say was much more antisemitic than um than salazar was well i think that there was this tradition in portugal of regretting uh the fact that the jewish population had gone to amsterdam and feeling that they'd really right they'd been robbed yes you know that had been a terrible mistake uh kind of hankering i suppose for what might have been so perhaps that's something that feeds into it i don't know tom have you been converted to lucifilia yes i completely have i really want to go to lisbon now yeah oh lisbon's a fantastic city absolutely stunning city one of the top so there are four great cities as you know in europe there is lisbon as i told you the other day lisbon vienna
是的，我完全是。我现在真的很想去里斯本。噢，里斯本是个梦幻般的城市，绝对美妙的城市，欧洲最好的城市之一。如你所知，欧洲有四个伟大的城市：里斯本——就像我前几天对你说的，里斯本、维也纳、
stockholm and wolverhampton yeah okay two of them effectively portuguese cities actually these days yes of course wolverhampton yeah absolutely um i will go uh because obviously you know as i said i i associate portugal with sunburn to my buttocks. Is that the image on which we're really going to end this podcast? I'm prepared to overlook that. I feel that you have educated me. And in fact, to a degree, I've educated myself because I've really enjoyed reading up on it.
斯德哥尔摩和沃尔夫汉普顿。是的，好吧，其中两个实际上是葡萄牙城市，如今是的，当然，沃尔夫汉普顿，绝对是的。嗯，我会去的。因为很明显，正如我所说，我把葡萄牙和晒伤我的屁股联系在一起。这就是我们要结束这个播客的形象吗？我准备忽略这一点。我觉得你教育了我。事实上，某种程度上我也教育了我自己，因为我真的很喜欢阅读相关资料。
I like to think we've all been educated, Tom. So on that bombshell, we will say adeus to all of you. You can go off and listen to your Fado music and help yourself to Pastéis de Nata. And we will return with, I can't even remember what we're doing next week, but it'll be absolutely riveting. It'll be great, won't it?
我想我们都受到了教育，汤姆。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们要向你们所有说再见了。你们可以去听你们的法多音乐，顺便吃点蛋挞。我们会回来的——我甚至不记得我们下周要做什么，但绝对会引人入胜。会很棒的，对吧？
It'll be brilliant. It will indeed. So enjoy that, and we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
这会很精彩。确实如此。所以好好享受吧，我们到时见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点娱乐圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，请前往——本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。